[Musique]
nous sommes trois ans après le big bang
trois ans après l'élection de
marie-guite dufay à la tête d'une
nouvelle région la bourgogne franche
comté et pour en parler nous sommes ici
à besançon dans les locaux de la région
voisin partenaires concurrents meilleur
ami meilleur ennemi la franche comté la
bourgogne c'est tout ça à la fois et
nous allons essayer avec marie-guite
dufay de faire le bilan de ces trois ans
de comprendre le travail de cette
collectivité régionale vous le voyez
dans la tempête qui se lève dans un
monde en pleine transition avec son
opposition mais aussi avec des
représentants de ce qui fait notre
région ont rejoint tout de suite
catherine à l'intérieur avec marie-guite
dufay et tous les invités
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
salon raymond forni donc à besançon
merci à marie-guite dufay la présidente
socialiste du conseil régional de
bourgogne franche comté de nous
accueillir ici chez elle alors je vous
présente les invités et les différents
thèmes que nous allons aborder au cours
de cette heure d'émission
tout d'abord nous allons parler des
territoires avec bruno bethenod
président des maires ruraux de côte-d'or
nous allons parler agriculture avec deux
agriculteurs thierry chalmin et jérôme
gojats transition écologique et
transport avec claire mallard d'europe
écologie les verts et patrick noblet de
la fnaut et puis un large dossier sera
consacrée à l'économie
nous avons invité philippe pillot qui
est syndicaliste force ouvrière chez
alstom et david butter qui est le patron
du medef de côte-d'or
nous comptons sur karine demnati
étudiants et vice président de
l'université pour nous parler jeunesse
et enseignement supérieur
vincent petit enseignants à travailler
sur l'histoire et la fusion et puis
sandrine décembre elle nous dira tout
sur l'image de la bourgogne franche
comté sur les réseaux sociaux
je n'oublie pas bien sûr les deux
conseillers régionaux d'opposition
hélène pélissard des républicains qui
représente ici le groupe l érudit et
julien odoul qui est le président du
groupe rassemblement national à la
région on se souvient que cette fusion
des régions a été discuté en souvient
aussi que la bourgogne franche comté été
pilote dans le mouvement
donc la première question que nous
allons nous poser vous poser trois ans
après c'est est ce que ça valait la
peine
est ce que les citoyens ce que les
territoires de la région s'y retrouve
est ce que quelque chose a été créé et
en commençant marie-guite dufay par vous
demander pourquoi vous souhaitiez que
cette émission se déroule à besançon
c'est que la vie politique se passe
entre dijon et besançon
est ce que c'est parce qu'il faut
équilibrer encore et toujours trois ans
après ne cherchez pas trop
besançon et le siège de la région le
siège politique de la région bourgogne
france comptait donc ça me semblait
normal à l'occasion de ce bilan alors
permettez-moi de vous de vous accueillir
puis de vous dire mon émotion de vous
accueillez ici dans le salon
raymond forni avec une sculpture là qui
a été fait à la mémoire de raymond forni
donc c'est pour moi un moment de très
très grande émotion
est ce que vous pensez trois ans plus
tard que la région c'est toujours les
cherokee et pertinents écouter
aujourd'hui fait régional s'impose vous
dire que les institutions sont au top
dans notre région je ne dirais pas ça et
la complexité institutionnelle elle est
là mais en même temps le fait régional
s'impose il n'y a pas un secteur
d'activité que ce soit économie
agriculture écologie transports qui n'en
appellent à la région chaque jour en dix
ans mais que va faire la région comment
la région va compléter le plan de
financement
que fait la région que nous conseille la
région le fait régional s'impose donc il
nous faut être à la hauteur de cette
attente
on va commencer tout de suite par parler
des territoires avec bruno bethenod
c'est le maire d'ars aux 900 habitants
il est président de l'association des
maires ruraux de côte-d'or
vous avez la parole pour parler des
territoires et de la ruralité monsieur
veto
oui merci ma la présidente
oui le fait régional s'impose et il
s'impose d'autant plus à d'autres
territoires ou territoires ruraux qui
souvent ont été plus ou moins délaissé
dans les différentes politiques
alors c'est pas forcément par une manque
de volonté c'est sans doute par une
manque de cohérence dans les volontés on
le voit à différents niveaux
aujourd'hui on est sur les trois ans
de gestion un nouveau mandat sur les
grandes régions on va pas refaire le
débat du pour ou contre les grandes
régions ça nous amènera seulement ce que
l'on peut dire c'est qu'il ya eu de la
gestion je dirais de l'intendance pour
faire simple et que on a perdu un petit
peu de temps dans l'application de
certains programmes et les territoires
ruraux en entre guillemets un peu
souffert notamment on peut reprendre
cela comme sujet sur les fonds européens
les foi ont repeint sont quelque chose
de très complexe et je ne mets pas la
cause sur le conseil régional de
bourgogne
je mets la cause sur l'évolution
législative qui a fait que on a forcé
des regroupements sans forcément trop
d'étude d'impact et l'intendance a fait
que eh bien c'est problème devait être
réglé et les problèmes concrets de
contractualisation ont pris du retard
on va laisser marie-guite dufay
répondent à cette question la réalité
très rapidement la ruralité c'est un
enjeu essentiel pour notre région
pour moi il ya deux choses qui sont
essentiels dans notre région c'est la
présence très fort de la ruralité et
puis le poids industrielle donc sa
marque notre région nous avons décidé de
mettre en place des contrats avec tous
les niveaux de territoire qui dit
comptera dix engagements financiers pour
partager avec tous les territoires leurs
besoins et mettre des moyens en face
donc nous avons une politique qui est
destiné à la fois aux grandes villes à
la métropole dijonnaise et aux autres
villes et à toute la ruralité puisque
nous avons 35 contrats dans la ruralité
90 millions d'euros d'engager mais quand
vous vous faites allusion au retard pris
sur les
dans le cadre des fonds européens vous
faites probablement allusion au
programme leader qui est un très très
bon programme effectivement pour amener
des fonds européens sur des programmes
de développement rural et ce programme
ne marche pas mais comme vous l'avez dit
c'est pas la faute de la région la faute
de l'europe c'est la faute de tout le
monde je suis en train d'interpeller
connaît des élections européennes je
suis anti fades ou non et je pense que
c'est beaucoup plus la faute de l'état
français parce que il y à aujourd'hui
quand même une difficulté de l'état a
considéré que les régions sont devenues
autorités de gestion à part entière il
ya encore beaucoup de décisions
bien qu'on soit autorités de gestion et
à dire que nous on voit l'argent passe
et on la tribu en instruit les dossiers
la tribu mais les raids
elles font encore fixé au niveau de
l'état et sur les fonds leader
il ya eu une avalanche de retard
technique de retard dans la gestion des
outils de changement des modes de
d'instruction des dossiers
c'est l'illustration même d'un d'une
note voilà on va dire qu'il ne
fonctionne pas donc je suis d'accord
avec vous avez pas je suis en train
d'interpeller l'état sur cette question
vous avez parlé de l' axe dijon besançon
on va 2 a donné une seconde on va donner
la parole à à karim bennati si ça vous
dérange pas parce que justement comment
on parlait de l' axe dijon besançon
karim bennati qui est étudiant en
médecine qui a 25 ans il est également
vice président de l'université
il a une question à vous poser justement
sur cet axe besançon dijon journée mme
dufay vous savez certainement que
l'université de bourgogne et
l'université de franche-comté collaborer
ensemble notamment dans le cadre de
certaines formations qu à créditer donc
où les étudiants ont des cours à
besançon et à dijon et pour certains
d'entre eux donc ça représente entre 200
et 300 étudiants au total ils sont
amenés donc à se déplacer entre besançon
et dijon et jusqu'à aujourd'hui la
région compenser une bonne partie des
traits déplacement qui est à engendrer
justement par ces cours donc est ce que
la raison contre nouvelle opération pour
la rentrée 2010 9 et par extension
que comptez vous faire pour améliorer le
transport donc entre lax besançon 10 ont
justement pour les étudiants en général
puisque étudiants de moins de 25 ans
payent
15 euros donc aller retour en ter et
plus de 25 ans pays 30 euros après de
façon générale je pense que nous n'avons
pas l'intention de nous n'avons pas
l'intention de revenir en arrière par
rapport à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
pour faciliter effectivement les
échanges d'étudiants entre dijon et
besançon
mais vous savez sur l' axe dijon
besançon en termes d'offre de transport
je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est quand même
très très conséquent et puis quant aux
tarifs ils sont aussi aujourd'hui parmi
les plus bas de france qui nous a amenés
mais on y reviendra tout à l'heure
probablement avoir une augmentation de
fréquentation
donc je suis pas sûr que le premier
combat ça soit celui de la mobilité pour
les étudiants entre dijon et besançon
mais le combat pour l'université c'est
vraiment que les universitaires de
bourgogne de franche-comté que
l'université de bourgogne l'université
de franche comté et l'utbm prennent les
moyens de travailler ensemble d'avoir
une voix unique pour défendre notamment
à l'international
le grand problème le grand programme de
labellisation parce que pour l'instant
ça marche parce que aujourd'hui alors la
commune on me dit on me dit depuis deux
mois que les choses s'améliorent il ya
eu un conseil d'administration de la
commue qui est donc l'établissement qui
rassemble nos trois universités et trop
et tous les établissements
universitaires
il y à une amélioration il ya un enjeu
très fort cette université qui est très
forte qui a des laboratoires à la pointe
qui ont un niveau européen de
reconnaissance ils ont un label à
maintenir ça s'appelle la belle visite
je veux pas rentrer dans les détails
techniques derrière c'est beaucoup
d'argent c'est trop d'argent et il faut
vraiment qu'ils arrivent à renouveler
est ce que le fait qu'ils aient du mal à
fonctionner ensemble c'est un petit peu
un effet de la difficulté au bout de
trois ans d'avoir créer quelque chose de
nouveau est ce que est ce que c'en est
un symptôme est ce que vous le voyez
comme ça non l'université a commencé à
travailler ensemble entre bourgogne et
franche-comté bien avant bien avant la
fusion
donc ça n'a rien à voir mais il y a une
difficulté intrinsèque on le voit
repenser de françois rebsamen le maire
de 10
jean qui lors des journées portes
ouvertes de l'université de franche
comté a fait une campagne de 4 par 3
dans les rues de la ville pour vanter
dijon capitale régionale de l'université
va écouter ce que je pense et basse et
l'autre chose c'est la traduction que
l'université de bourgogne franche comté
n'est pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu qui
est le sien parce que la campagne elle
devrait être universités bourgogne
franche comté à la fois en interne dans
toute notre région pour dire tout le
potentiel qu'il ya pour les étudiants
dans notre université et surtout elle
devrait être à l'extérieur dans les
régions voisines pour attirer les
étudiants dans notre région parce qu'on
a vraiment des enseignants qui sont top
on a des chercheurs qui sont reconnus au
niveau européen on a des traits vraiment
des très très bons atouts au niveau
universitaire et on ne sait pas
aujourd'hui les communiqués donc moi je
m'adresse à l'université réveillez vous
mais l'université elle le sait je n'ai
cessé depuis trois ans de tenir ce
discours allant même jusqu'à menacer de
retirer des crédits parce que la région
amène des crédits importants à
l'université mais nous ne sommes pas
l'âge je suis sûr que la raison
l'emportera mais il est temps il est
temps on va faire un peu de politique
aussi il ya la représentation de la
société civile et puis les groupes
d'opposition helen pélissard trois ans
après le démarrage de cette nouvelle
région
est ce que vous auriez fait pareil mais
trois ans après le fait régional et bien
écoutez pour le moment dans la région
c'est une augmentation des frais de
fonctionnement
c'est une augmentation des impôts pour
les franc comtois puisqu'on a remonté
les cartes grises de 36 à 51 euros et on
a enlevé 16 millions de pouvoir d'achat
aux francs comtois le fait régional
aujourd'hui il fonctionne pas il y à
l'organisation en miroir de cette région
fait une multiplication du nombre de
fonctionnaires ça ne marche pas alors la
faute va on va donner la parole à julien
au dulce ça vous dérange parier pour
leur assemblée nationale je voudrais a
préféré un mot sur la commune oui ce
qu'il faut quand même rappeler c'est
pourquoi cette fusent
on a été décidé clairement c'était pas
pour améliorer le quotidien les
habitants ce n'est pas pour renforcer
notre territoire
cette fusion qui étaient décidées par
françois hollande est accompagné par
marie-guite dufay
c'était pour répondre aux desiderata
l'union européenne pour affaiblir les
états nations et participer de cette
vision fédéraliste il faut le rappeler
la fusion c'est ça et puis ensuite pour
les bourguignons et les franc-comtois la
fusion on peut dire que ces trahisons et
mensonge mensonge puisque marie-guite
dufay sur france 3 en juin 2014 annonce
est évidemment il y aura des économies
faux puisque les dépenses de
fonctionnement augmentent et nous ronge
pourtant elle disait également donc sur
france 3 appareils à la même date que
n'est ce pas voyager elle disait elle
disait également que la priorité des
priorités c'était le dynamisme
économique alors que le chômage augmente
et on était on le joue un détail
important l ai dit aussi que c'était
plus de proximité ce qui est totalement
faux puisque nos compatriotes nos
compatriotes le voit avec notamment une
étude de l'institut montaigne qui montre
que 82 % des bourguignons des francs
comtois déplore la suppression des
services publics de proximité répondre
oui alors l'explosion des frais de
fonctionnement il faut faire très
attention à ceux dont on parle
les dépenses de fonctionnement ont
augmenté à la région oui pour augmenter
le service apporté aux citoyens pour
augmenter le service public c'est à dire
les dépenses d'intervention de la région
pour la formation des demandeurs
d'emploi pour le fonctionnement des
trains pour le fonctionnement des lycées
oui nous avons augmenté l'addition des
deux budgets de bourgogne et de
franche-comté c'était 300 millions et en
d'investissement on est aujourd'hui à
500 millions d'investissements
donc oui nous avons augmenté les
dépenses d'intervention au service du
développement de notre région
nous n'avons pas augmenté le nombre de
fonctionnaires comme je viens d'entendre
et nous avons fait des économies
oui il y a eu des économies sur ce qu'on
appelle les charges fonctionnel sur des
procédures d'achats sur des études qui
au lieu des économies ça correspondait
au j'allais dire au bon ordre
on a on a fait des économies mais cette
si ça veut dire quoi faire des économies
est ce que c'est sur le dos des services
qu'on rend aux citoyens ou est-ce que
c'est sur autre chose si c'est sur autre
chose c est si lon dans le budget d'une
région et moi je vois d'autres régions
qui ne sont pas de ma famille qui se
sont targués éventé dès le début du
mandat de faire des économies parce
qu'elles ont réduit le train de vie de
la région les réceptions les chauffeurs
les voitures mais nous on n'avait pas un
train de vie donc on n'avait pas à faire
ce type d'économie
donc il faut faire très attention et
quand on se voit on
il ya un ratio qui s'appelle le taux
d'administration où on compare le nombre
de personnes qui travaillent dans la
collectivité par rapport à l'ensemble du
budget ma note budget il a augmenté d'un
tiers et le nombre de personnes de la
collectivité les mêmes c'est à dire
qu'on a toujours le même nombre de
personnes pour traiter un tiers de deux
démarches en plus parce qu'on a voulu
augmenter on appris en général le
meilleur de la bourgogne et le meilleur
de la franche comté que ça soit au
service de la culture du développement
économique de l'écologie est
effectivement au s'est donné les moyens
d'augmenter parce qu'on avait on avait
des ratios financiers qui nous le
permettait nous avons été élus pour
faire du développement pour tous et ce
développement
si vous avez dit le meilleur de la
bourgogne maire de la franche-comté ça
nous permet de rebondir sandrine
descendre vous êtes vous invitez parce
que les spécialistes de la communication
numérique et est-ce qu'elle existe de
votre point de vue la bourgogne franche
comté trois ans après est ce qu'on la
voit alors qu'elles existent pour ma
part je vais en revenir à une question
concernant la ruralité qui pour moi est
au coeur de nos vies qui que nous soyons
la ruralité c'est important on est dans
nos villages dans nos petites villes on
n'est pas on vit pas tous dans des
grandes villes
alors peut-on faire déjà des économies
aujourd'hui à l'heure du numérique
lorsque l'on souhaite vivre dans ces
petits villages et dans ces villes et
travailler parce que je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui le haut très haut débit
c'est la question que vous posez le très
haut débit
c'est l'équivalent de l'eau et de
l'électricité aujourd'hui
alors c'est pal malheureusement je
dirais ou heureusement pour une experte
en numérique c'est à eux un peu
compliqué dire ça mais c'est pas le
débat toutefois aujourd'hui où on est
ton à l'ère du numérique madame du fait
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire je
crois qu on a 160 millions me
semble-t-il alors je me trompe peut-être
d'investissement sur le numérique
où en est-on en termes d'inclusion et de
ruralité en particulier mais ça c'est le
sujet numéro un pour la ruralité
moi je crois à l'avenir de la ruralité à
partir du moment où il y aura la fibre
partout et donc aujourd'hui nous sommes
massivement engagés aux côtés des
départements parce que ce sont les
départements qui ont la maîtrise
d'oeuvre sur les travaux pour amener la
fibre et nous sommes massivement à
hauteur de 160 millions d'euros vous
avez parfaitement raison
à leurs côtés et nous avons même mis en
place des procédés pour que s'ils vont
encore plus vite ils soient bonifiés
et puis il ya des territoires ruraux où
on sait que de toute façon malgré les
efforts de tout le monde
la fibre on leur a pas avant quatre ans
ou cinq ans et donc on s'est donné les
moyens d'amener néanmoins du très haut
débit par une autre technologique est
une technologie radio par la voie
hertzienne
ça s'appelle la technologie air cube et
donc nous avons un programme qui se
déploie et qui permet que dans les
réalités vraiment éloigné où la fibre
n'arrivera pas avant quatre ou cinq ans
néanmoins il y ait du très haut débit à
disposition ses airs cube et en plus
tous les frais d'installation de ce
réseau hercules sont complètement pris
par la région c'est totalement gratuit
pour les communes
donc après effectivement l'usagé à son
abonnement à faire ouvrir en charge du
numérique devait signer une
une charte concernant l'inclusion ou non
et on oui mais on travaille je pense
qu'on est reconnue comme une région
expérimental par rapport à cette
question parce que on veut développer
une fois qu'on a installé les
infrastructures pour numérique il faut
développer les usages 1 et là on est
dans tous les domaines que ce soit le
domaine de la santé le domaine des
lycées le domaine de l'économie
on est complètement engagé dans cette
affaire là avec le souci qu
effectivement ceux qui sont peut-être
les plus éloignés de ses usages soient
formés donc on a un gros programme de
formation à ces niveaux là on va donner
maintenant la parole à vincent petit qui
est professeur d'histoire qui a publié
un livre comment peut-on encore être
franc comtois alors vous vous étiez très
inquiet il ya 3 4 ans justement que
dijon et besançon tire la couverture à
elle est aujourd'hui
trois ans plus tard qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous qu'être avis sur ce sujet
j'ai regardé les manifestations des
défilés jaune comme tous et j'ai été
frappé par le devoir les drapeaux
régionaux
un conte trouvait parfois donc dans ces
manifestations et ma question elle est
très simple est ce que finalement la la
fusion et ses grandes régions et je
parle pas uniquement des bourgogne
franche comté moi aussi paraît qu'on
pourrait parler de grand test ou bien de
la delà de l'occitanie ou de la nouvelle
aquitaine mais finalement est-ce que ces
grandes régions finalement on aggrave t
elle pas le processus de métropolisation
a décrit par christophe guy et
finalement aggravant fait la fracture
territoriale entre les français
effectivement entre besançon et dijon je
pense qu'il n'y a pas trop de soucis
pour c'est pour ces deux villes mais moi
je pense aux périphéries de la grande
région je pense au nord franche comté
je pense au jura au doux aux châtillons
mais une partie de la nièvre
donc voilà ma qui sont les traite est
toute simple est ce que ces grandes
régions finalement on aggrave t elle pas
ce processus de métropolisation qui est
finalement une injustice territoriale
criante pour les français d'aujourd'hui
notre démarche c'est de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait un équilibre entre la
réalité et la métropolisation
c'est pour ça que nous sommes engagés
dans une politique de contractualisation
passer des contrats non seulement avec
les villes qui doivent être aidés
notamment dans leurs charges
universitaire de recherche enfin ceux
qui les villes elles dépensent de
l'argent pas simplement pour leurs
citoyens mais pour tous ceux qui
viennent étudier qui viennent travailler
dans la ville donc il y à des charges
particulières à faire prendre aux
comptes
nous avons des contrats avec dijon avec
besançon avec le nord franche comté avec
le creusot mais nous avons gelé dit tout
à l'heure des contre un avec tous les
territoires et et notre montra un peu
ici à la région c'est vraiment de se
dire que parce que la région s'est
agrandi il fallait travailler la carte
de la proximité et la proximité c'est
ses contrats avec tous les territoires
c'est la mobilité aussi aujourd'hui et
puisqu'on aborde la deuxième partie du
mandat
les questions de mobilité les questions
de vie et de travail en milieu rural
sont des questions qui sont en train de
prendre de l'importance
nous avons une assemblée plénière dans
quinze jours où nous allons proposer un
certain nombre de mesures et notamment
des mesures liées à la mobilité en
milieu rural tout à fait expérimental au
niveau français alors la deuxième partie
de cette émission s'intitule la région
dans un monde en transition nous allons
pas être des évolutions en agriculture
de la transition énergétique et aussi
des transports notre région est la
région la plus rurale de france juste
derrière la corse
il y a seulement 59 habitons kilomètres
carrés alors la crise des gilets jaunes
vincent petit en a parlé à démarrer avec
la taxe sur les carburants
elle a mobilisé massivement chez nous et
justement les transports c'est l'une des
compétences fortes de la région
elle y consacre son premier poste de
dépenses avec 600 millions sur un budget
de 1 milliard 600 millions et nous
allons poser tout de suite la question à
patrick noblet c'est le vice président
de la fnaut tu laves d'autres c'est la
fédération nationale des associations
d'usagers des transports
donc monsieur noblet vous vous les
interrogez marie-guite dufay sur sa
politique ferroviaire notamment sur les
ter et sur les tgv oui mais pas
uniquement effectivement ferroviaire
mais de de mobilité en général
d'ailleurs
oui même le président vous connaissez la
sensibilité de nos concitoyens sur le
sujet mobilité la loi a donné à la
région le rôle de chef de file en
matière de mobilité et doit donner les
compétences ter maintenant bus
départementaux transport scolaire centre
de mobilité autonomie tarifaires et
il faut reconnaître que dans ce domaine
de gros efforts ont été faits et
effectivement la région consacre près de
40% de son budget c'est énorme à la
mobilité vous allez avoir un nouveau
levier avec l'élaboration du schéma
régional d'aménagement et de
développement durable je fais court qui
va s'imposer
qui va s'imposer à toutes les
collectivités
alors dans ce contexte vous avez toutes
les cartes en main pour la mobilité
quelles ambitions pour une mobilité
durable intermodal et tarifaires et qui
s'imposera sur tout le territoire de
montréal franche comté vaste question
l'ambition elle est au rendez vous
l'enjeu il est fondamental et
effectivement il n'ya pas de
développement sans mobilité
il n'y a pas de développement la
ruralité et de vie dans la ruralité si
ya pas de mobilité
mais le sujet il est partout donc notre
ambition elle est énorme
donc déjà au niveau des ter qui est
notre première compétence plus de train
c'est l'expression de notre nouvelle
convention avec les ter puisqu'on à dix
mille places supplémentaires des trains
qui soit plus régulier qui arrive
davantage à l'heure donc ça c'est
conditionné par les travaux qui sont
faits sur c'est un peu une sur les
avoirs le jardin de la sncf
oui des tarifs puisque nous avons une
liberté de fixer les tarifs et bien
qu'ils tiennent compte des questions de
pouvoir d'achat
nous avons sur les tarifs occasionnels
les tarifs les plus bas de france nous
avions fait un pari de baisser
énormément les tarifs en espérant que
cela amènerait de la population le pari
il a été réussi puisque on a doublé le
nombre de jeunes qui fréquentent nos
lignes je parle sur les tarifs
occasionnels sur les abonnements
nous avons élevé les tarifs
il y a deux mois parce qu'il n'avait pas
été relevé depuis cinq ans avec des
ajustements qui ont été nécessaire parce
que il ya eu une information qui n'a pas
été disons au top en direction des
usagers
donc j'ai voulu qu'effectivement les
usagers et un mois gratuit ou deux mois
gratuits pour compenser mais autrement
on est vraiment dans des dents une ligne
2 qui tient vraiment vraiment content
des questions de pouvoir d'achat
au delà des ter il y a via la mobilité
en milieu rural la n'y a pas de thé vert
on fait comment et l'après
des gilets journal ait partie de ça des
personnes qui habitent en milieu rural
et qui ont du mal à terminer leurs fins
de mois notamment avec l'augmentation
des coûts de l'essence dont il y avait
la taxe carbone qui a été la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase
donc j'ai souhaité à cette occasion
faire un travail de co-construction avec
le monde économique avec les partenaires
des entreprises parce que les salariés
qui habitent en milieu rural
ils ont un peu une double peine ce qui
habitent en milieu urbain ils peuvent se
faire rembourser par leur employeur la
moitié de leurs c'est la loi de leurs
frais de déplacement en ruralité ya rien
alors seulement proposer quoi à ce qui
complique et et construction c'est très
flou à battre construction c'est qu'on
travaille ensemble d'accords donc je
travaillais pour inventer quoi j'ai
travaillé avec le medef avait classé pme
et avec lui de pella le monde de
l'artisanat pour aboutir à un ticket
mobilité il ya des tickets restaurants
dans l'est dans les entreprises voilà
qu'on mette en place un ticket mobilité
pour les personnes qui habitent en
milieu rural et puis qui remplissent un
certain nombre de conditions en termes
de distance et de salaire par exemple à
l'élément je voulais relancer claire
mallard prenait le micro de votre point
de vue du point de vue d'europe écologie
ce que propose marie-guite dufay ce que
propose la région en termes de mobilité
aujourd'hui de nouveautés peut-être dans
l'immobilité est ce que pour vous c'est
à la hauteur est ce que parce que c'est
ça que vous avez envie de nous très
concrètes
le très concrètement on a on a des
solutions aujourd'hui on ne comprend pas
que la région continue investir dans
deux aéroports régionaux dole tavaux et
dijon bourgogne qui sont pourtant
déficitaire sans retombées économiques
locales pour les territoires comme l'a
démontré la cour des comptes et on pense
que la région fort ferait mieux de
mettre cet argent fin de ces deux puits
sans fond faut quand même dire ce qu'ils
sont sur la modernisation des réseaux de
trains pour permettre aux habitants
rapidement de se déplacer sans leur
voiture et de réduire le nombre de
camions sur les routes
ça aussi c'est un enjeu et on regrette
fortement aussi au lieu de vous que vous
ayez supprimer les haltes ferroviaires
de neuilly-lès-dijon defrasne et de
villers les pots et que la modernisation
et que la modernisation
delà du tronçon janine baer de la vf cea
ne se met pas en route du ferret pointe
sur cette question alors les aéroports
d'abord celui de dijon n'est pas
déficitaire et celui de dole tavaux
alors aujourd'hui il est déficitaire moi
j'ai toujours dit que au nom du
développement économique et notamment au
nom du développement touristique de
notre région il difficile de tirer un
trait sur cet aéroport
mais il faut changer transformer son
modèle économique c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a que des
personnes qui viennent à l'aéroport et
qui partent dans les pays du sud pour
leur voyage et je souhaite que l'on
fasse venir de la population du nord de
l'angleterre de des pays scandinaves du
nord de l'allemagne et qui s'arrêtent
chez nous et qui viennent dépenser de
l'argent chez nous à dijon à dole dans
le jura ain dans les dans les caves
bourguignonne dans les lacs jurassiens
donc il ya un modèle à transformer et
c'est ce à quoi nous travaillons
après vous m'avez parlé de la
suppression alors on n'a pas su pied n'a
pas supprimé de halte à frasne 1
parce que vous n'avez parlé de frasne
j'aurais parlé de frasne parce qu'il ya
un vrai sujet aujourd'hui au niveau
régional qui est extrêmement grave pour
notre région c'est la suppression d'une
desserte tgv que nous avons apprises de
la part de la compagnie lyria dans
laquelle la sncf à 70% des parts et à
frasne donc il y aurait comme à dijon
comme à dole une desserte tgv au moins
et là nous nous battons nous nous
battons parce que s'ils commencent à y
avoir des dessertes tgv qui sont
supprimés sur cet axe là qui est le
massif concours jurassien qui est la
proximité avec la frontière suisse
bah on commence à tourner le dos à notre
région puisque cette desserte qui est
supprimé à les remplacer par une
desserte qui passe par genève et par
bourg-en-bresse pour aller à paris c'est
le début du contournement de notre
région c'est pas admissible et c'est
pour cela que je mène une mobilisation
très forte sur toute la région
juste le point de vue d entre eux des
entreprises et des entrepreneurs là
dessus on parlait de construction tout à
l'heure sur des politiques de
en sport est ce que ça vous semble une
bonne idée est ce que vous il ya des
demandes que vous avez là dessus pas
complètement et on est totalement
d'accord pour co-construire et au
contraire on s'est rencontrés plusieurs
fois avec madame buffet avec les équipes
une manière globale je vais revenir sur
l'aéroport avec une autre façon de voir
les choses sans doute ces deux
d'envisager finalement des échanges avec
d'autres bassins économiques d'une
manière globale ou parler du tourisme
évidemment c'est aussi faire venir des
gens qui consomment ici mais finalement
quand on regarde et qu'on analyse les
grands aéroports d'une manière globale à
l'échelle internationale généralement on
est à 1h30 2h de notre destination dans
tous les déplacements touristiques et ou
économique
donc nous pensons qu'un aéroport à
l'échelle régionale régionale n'a pas de
viabilité économique
si vous êtes une entreprise pour le
gérer on le ferait pas comme ça en
revanche il y à un aéroport et un homme
formidable qui s'appelle roissy charles
de gaulle qui est complètement
accessible avec un axe qui peut partir
de lausanne passé par besançon ensuite
dijon montbard et finalement irriguer
toute la région voire pourquoi pas
belfort et mulhouse qui existent aussi
et là c'est une discussion énorme à
avoir avec les acteurs économiques sans
doute et les acteurs politiques auprès
de la sncf j'ai vu très récemment qu'il
y avait sans doute une surreprésentation
une saturation de la ligne paris-lyon
il ne faudrait pas que nous soyons
sanctionné sur notre région au profit de
paris lyon et ça c'est un danger majeur
et au contraire qu'on en demande encore
plus en terme de cadencement pour alessi
roissy charles de gaulle et faire de
l'économique les manière globale une
priorité une réponse rapide
il ya déjà eu des essais et ces essais
n'ont pas été concluants parce que la
population n'était pas au rendez-vous
mais j'entends bien c'est une sont des
éléments de débat que vous amenez
effectivement je les entends bien
maintenant koné sur les transports
l'économie
je voudrais donner la parole à qui
richelle manqué le président de la
chambre d'agriculture de haute saône
pourquoi la haute-saône parce que c'est
le département de bourgogne franche
comté qui a le plus souffert de la
sécheresse lors de l'été dernier alors
je voudrais savoir comment ça s'est
passé
si ça s'est bien passé et vous ce que
vous attendez de la région ça s'est
passé effectivement mieux que l'épisode
climatique qui s'est lui très mal passée
en haute saône c'est sûr il reste
quelques petits réglages à faire madame
la présidente eu votre capacité à
intervenir d'urgence cette possible sur
cet événement climatique il faudra qu'on
en reparle
moi je veux simplement dire que sur cet
épisode comme surtout beaucoup d'autres
politiques agricoles proximité égale
efficacité quoi donc une région à l
écoute des territoires à l'écouté de
leurs besoins
c'est une nécessité impérieuse mon
sentiment dans la partie agricole c'est
que les trois ans qui viennent de
s'écouler a été quelque part des
fiançailles de la bourgogne et de la
franche comté
maintenant il faut que deux voilà qu'il
faut que nous passions mariage pour
preuve c'est qu'en agriculture beaucoup
de il ya eu beaucoup d'agglomérations
des politiques bourguignonne à des
politiques franc comtoise les unes à
côté des autres
maintenant je compte dans les années qui
viennent il nous reste à mouliner tous à
conjuguer tout ça pour faire vraiment
une politique régionale grande région
donc le chantier reste complètement
ouvert on vous allez passer le micro à
votre voisin donc et jérôme beaujard de
la confédération paysanne
j'aimerais donc vous posez vos questions
à marie-guite dufay qu'elle nous fasse
une réponse globale sur l'agriculture
mais je suis un peu le maître des
horloges il faut aller assez vite oui
oui bonjour je voudrais tout de suite
aborder une question d'actualité parce
que on sait bien que l'agriculture est
une agriculture et d et que la région
bourgogne et et autorité de gestion mais
n'est pas très puissante financièrement
face à ces enjeux là on sait que
elle soutient autant qu'elle le peut
elle l'a fait pour le pour le plan
sécheresse
je voudrais poser une question au sujet
de l'agriculture biologique
on a on arrive à la suppression de
l'aide au maintien pour les agriculteurs
qui était déjà en agriculture biologique
la région a soutenu par une année de
transition pour éviter que les gens
soient dans la panade et on entend dire
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement
s'apprêterait à réduire la durée de
conversion ce que je souhaiterais savoir
c est ce que la région bourgogne franche
comté est prête à se battre pour qu'il y
ait une aide au maintien de
l'agriculture biologique c'est à dire
qu'une aide qui soit pérennisé dans le
temps parce que la société nous attend
la demande est là mais les agriculteurs
qui sont en agriculture biologique
doivent être reconnu par tout les
aspects positifs qu'apporte leur
pratique fait votre réponse
déjà l'agriculture biologique elle
bénéficie de fonds européen conséquent
par le biais de l'aide à la conversion
les agriculteurs qui se convertissent
ont une aide pendant trois ans ou quatre
ans je ne sais plus je mets pas si c'est
pas cinq ans ces cinq ans donc pendant
cinq ans il ya une aide à la conversion
et c'était dont on avait un petit peu
peur de ne plus avoir suffisamment de
moyens
d'ici là les nouveaux programmes
européens or on a réussi à organiser les
choses pour que ses moyens sont là donc
il n'y aura pas de baisse pour les
agriculteurs qui se convertissent l'aide
à la conversion de cinq ans elle ne sera
pas réduit et où se bat dans les années
futures pour les nouveaux programmes
pour que ça soit maintenu et peut-être
même amplifié on entend parler partout
de nécessité de verdir la politique
agricole donc les bio ils vont pas être
mis en difficulté après ce que vous
poser comme question c'est au delà des
50 conversion est ce qui peut y avoir
toujours une aide au maintien
alors là normalement
on peut estimer qu'au bout de cinq ans
les agriculteurs qui ont été aidées
rentrer dans le pack est normal et
bénéficie de toutes les aides qui l'y a
par ailleurs que ce soit sur la
modernisation de leurs bâtiments sur
différents investissements ou là on a
aussi des budgets importants mais on à
l'agriculteur l'agriculture bio
complètement en vigilance quand nous
demandons au lycée de faire en sorte que
dans les cantines il y ait 50 %
d'alimentation de proximité dont 20 %
bio c'est bien pour pousser à la
consommation d'agriculture bio et pour
pousser cette agriculture bio donc elle
fait intrinsèquement partie de nos
programmes
vous le savez puisque nous avons un
dialogue conséquent avec les deux
interprofessions de bourgogne et de
franche-comté un dialogue positif mais
par contre jamais nous ne mettrons en
place nous région une aide spécifique au
bout des cinq ans pour continuer un
comme ça se faisait auparavant et ça a
été supprimée par l'état parce que nous
on n'en veut pas mes moyens
alors je vous coupe parce que d'oise 20
minutes d'émission et on est bien sûr
battu par le temps je me tourne vers
vous pour terminer sur l'agriculture
hélène pélissard
parce que certains ont peut-être
remarqué que françois sauvadet au salon
de l'agriculture fait remarquer qu'ils
souhaitaient que la compétence agricole
reviennent au département ans oui oui
par ailleurs président du conseil
départemental de voile à ces nouveaux
points de vue écoutez madame du fai
vient de répondre
vous avez parlé de fiançailles avec la
région mais les fiançailles c'est pas
avec la région c'est avec l'ensemble des
collectivités
vous comprenez françois sauvadet a tout
à fait raison nous avons les
départements et la région préparer un
plan où tout le monde paye que ce soit
les départements où la région pour
soutenir la filière agricole je suis ici
je n'entend jamais parler de ce que les
départements apporte à au plan de madame
du fait et bien évidemment les
départements sont parfois un peu irrité
de voir que la région tire toujours la
couverture elle
alors ça c'est un premier point
je voulais le souligner c'est quand même
très dommage le plan d aide aux
agriculteurs c'est un plan régionaux
départemental et ça ça n'est jamais dit
moi je voudrais aussi revenir très
rapidement sur les aéroports alors les
aéroports madame je vous rassure tout de
suite ça n'est pas la région qui payent
pour l'aéroport de dole
c'est le département du jura nous avons
vous avez une contribution extrêmement
faible pour aider cet aéroport il ya un
sujet sur les aéroports je suis bien
d'accord avec vous il faut remettre ça
sur la table et voir si on peut avoir un
aéroport qui soit un aéroport viable sur
ce territoire mais certainement pas deux
sur la politique l'autre politique des
transports
moi je vous donnerai un satisfecit parce
que je pense que la région fait son
travail en matière de transport il y a
une chose madame la présidente à
laquelle il faudra qu'on fasse très
attention c'est que dans toutes les
territoires ruraux on puisse avoir accès
à des billets de trains et la fermeture
des gares et la fermeture des guichets
est une catastrophe pour la ruralité ça
alors peut-être avec des maisons de
service public et des ont parlé aussi
des buralistes
il ya dirait bien avoir la parole sont
obligés de vous un dossier extrêmement
important c'est la commune et j'aurais
peut-être utiliser une partie de mon
temps madame je voudrais vraiment vous
dire sur la commune quand vous nous
dites il faut que les présidents
d'université sont andes
oui monsieur rebsamen a fait une erreur
considérable avec 7,7 publicité qu'il a
fait ici à besançon mais vous avez votre
part de responsabilité je voudrais
vraiment que vous mettiez devant vous
responsabilité s'agissant de la commune
d'abord cette région vous l'avez voulu
monsieur rebsamen n'a pas voulu il
aurait fallu anticiper un peu avec les
présidents de région pour préparer cet
ensemble universitaire régional
et puis deuxièmement vous donnez 33
millions par an à l'université pour
fonctionner monsieur rebsamen s'il veut
travailler tout seul madame je vous
demande de lui supprimer les subventions
de la région de l'université de dijon
s'il veut travailler tous à l'hyper à
tout seul
et qu'après vous nous ferez une réponse
est oui sur wii sur les transports
revenez sur les transports il faut que
les bourguignons et franc-comtois sache
que la fusion c'est plus d'impôts sur la
mobilité
on l'a vu avec le matraquage des
automobilistes et que l'augmentation de
la carte grise on le voit aussi avec
l'augmentation des abonnements ter
ensuite sur la proximité puisque avec
les suppressions de guichets de gare
donc dans certaines gares rural
évidemment ça pose tombe de problème
pour l'achat l'achat des billets et puis
les conditions aussi de transport au
niveau de la sécurité qui était
profondément dégradées après sur le
ticket mobilité je pense qu'il faut
rendre aussi au rassemblement national
ce qui appartient au rassemblement
national ça a été une proposition de
notre groupe propose aux orientations
budgétaires obligent et que vous avez
refusé de manière tactique
bon vous allez il concédé pour pour le
mois de mars est une bonne chose mais je
pense que ça aurait pu être en commun et
un travail un travail concerté sur
l'agriculture
moi je souligne le manque de
volontarisme la région de votre majorité
sur la défense la promotion des circuits
courts puisque dans nos cantines les
cantines de nos lycées nous ne sommes
pas encore à 50 % de produits de la
région c'est totalement inadmissible
nous avions proposé au groupe assemblée
nationale qui est 100% de viande et de
légumes issus des territoires de la
région pour encore une fois favoriser
favoriser nos agriculteurs c'est une
priorité des missions voudrais parler un
peu de transition et de climat et parler
des entreprises sur l'agriculture il ya
eu la sécheresse ça a été dramatique
dans notre région j'ai voulu qu'il y ait
une seule voix qui parle la voix des
territoires
la voix de notre région et quand je dis
la région c'est dans son ensemble hélène
pélissard
vous savez que j'ai demandé à ce que la
région travaille avec tous les
départements et avec toute la profession
agricole pour qu'on ait un plan massif
d'intervention je pense qu'on a été la
seule région de france à voir ce plan
massif et moi je suis plutôt fier qu'on
ait pu avoir cette voie ou enfin régions
et départements travaillent ensemble
parce que le président de la chambre
départementale d'agriculture de la ddt
de haute saône a raison c'est vrai que
la complexité institutionnelle fait que
ça a été compliqué je crois que
maintenant c'est derrière nous cette
complication
on sait qu'on ne peut faire face à des
enjeux importants qu'en étant ensemble
et soudée et le premier enjeu pour
l'agriculture maintenant c'est la
question du réchauffement climatique de
la prévention des aléas climatiques et
donc c'est travailler massivement sur la
recherche sur les nouvelles techniques
de production et là nous avons introduit
dans cette région une pratique qui était
une pratique franc-comtoise elle est
devenue une pratique pour l'ensemble de
la région c'est de travailler par
filière on ne peut être efficace avec
l'agriculture que si on travaille par
filière la filière du lait standard la
filière bovine la filière des céréales
la filière bio aussi par filière ce qui
ne se faisait pas en bourgogne
donc on y va on est résolu mais
l'agriculture
c'est vraiment la question de demain
quelle agriculture de demain plus sobre
en consommation d'eau plus robuste pour
résister aux aléas climatiques et la
nôtre en jeu il est vraiment sur la sur
la recherche allez on avance et on va
parler à tout type de climat claire
mallard de d'énergie et de climat
on va essayer de parler de ça et on va
parler des entreprises bien sûr et de la
façon dont la région que peut jouer un
rôle
il nous reste un quart d'heure démission
pour essayer de structurer sa proprement
claire mallard qu'est-ce que alors voilà
bien un peu mieux faire la région je
vais quand même répondre sur les
aéroports
excusez moi mais de toute façon ça fait
partie des urgences pour madame juste
pour madame pélissard justement
l'urgence climatique c'est quoi c'est
aujourd'hui de mettre l'argent sur les
transports du quotidien les transports
non polluants donc les trains donc le
peu con mais c'est de toute façon une
aberration surtout quand on a des
aéroports internationaux sono à
proximité voilà je voulais quand même
vous le dire là il faut le dire voilà
c'est dit viser l'accession énergie sur
la question de la transition énergétique
je crois qu'il faut saluer l'objectif
d'une région à énergie positive en 2050
ça c'est quelque chose de positif
néanmoins face à l'urgence climatique
aux attentes des jeunes pour qu'ils sont
soucieux de leur avenir et qui vont
faire la grève pour le climat à tous les
marcheurs du climat je crois qu'on a
besoin de politiques qui soient
cohérentes et courageuse elle a alors
essayé deux minutes là on note quand
même des contradictions alors en matière
de politique énergétique
il y en a une importante donc vous
poursuivez une politique énergétique
satisfaisante
initié par les élus écologistes sous les
mandats précédents je pense aux
dispositifs effilogis au plan bourgogne
bâtiment durable
mais alors j'ai une question
fondamentale allez vous coûte que coûte
installer un climat tropical dans une
zone de montagne et dans une zone
tempérée avec les énergivores center
parcs qui de plus vont menacer la
ressource en eau alors que les périodes
de sécheresses vont s'intensifier salle
juste pour center parcs y en a deux qui
sont prévues en franche comté
donc 1 en bourgogne et en bourgogne et
en franche comté en franche-comté ccta
pollini donc il y à une opposition
farouche contre ces symptômes parc vous
répondez quoi c'est un vrai sujet de
débat moi j'ai posé des conditions
les conditions écologiques des
conditions financières une faisabilité
financière qui aujourd'hui n'est pas au
rendez vous et effectivement des
conditions écologiques par rapport à la
préservation de la ressource en eau mais
aujourd'hui on en est même pas à l'étude
de ces conditions là parce qu'on est sur
des questions de paix et lui et de
réglementations qui font qu'aujourd'hui
les deux en local et des initiés sont
complètement enlisé et on n'est pas
encore en situation de me répondre sur
les conditions que j'ai mise mais moi je
disais vous venez de celle moi je les
soutiendrai pas un projet de center
parcs qui par ailleurs peut être
intéressant pour le développement
économique et la création d'emploi local
si les conditions que j'ai mise au
niveau écologique et au niveau de
l'ingénierie financière ne sont pas
résolues rapatrient leurs marques en
bourgogne franche comté a tout de suite
alors vous parler d'économie justement
c'était la suite ce dont on voulait
parler pour essayer de savoir si le
conseil régional comment ils
accompagnent comment il prépare
finalement
le monde qui vient parce que c'est ça
aussi ça fait partie de vos compétences
david butter vous attendez quoi vous du
conseil régional dans la vie des
entreprises dans et dans la préparation
peut-être à ce qui va venir écouter on
attend beaucoup de choses mais à la fois
on se débrouille tout seul l'entreprise
elle a quelque chose de particulier
c'est que cet animal en transition
permanent et qui subit en règle générale
tout ce qui peut se passer au niveau
politique pour ensuite créer la valeur
puisque la seule et unique création de
valeur à notre égard en tout cas elle
est créée par les entreprises
donc il faut pouvoir travailler ensemble
mois d'une manière globale sur certains
des débats qu'on ne peut vivre ce matin
je dirais j'ai mal à ma région temps en
temps parce que on a des atouts
formidables sur notre région les atouts
dans le tourisme dans le vin dans la
gastronomie dont beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qu'on pourrait mettre en avant
peut-être que c'est une forme de
communication aussi recréé tous ensemble
pour être cher de ce qu'on fait
peut-être qu'on l'ait pas assez dans
notre région à l'échelle de la bourgogne
franche comté aujourd'hui peut-être
aussi être beaucoup plus en proximité
les entreprises sont naturellement plus
facilement en proximité entre la
bourgogne la franche comté que d'autres
organisations puisque du tout de toute
façon c'est une logique financière est
connue qu'à la fin qui vient sanctionner
compte hier on connaît aucune frontière
mais même au delà de la frontière de la
bourgogne franche comté bien évidemment
je parlais des aéroports tout à l'heure
ça nous semble juste simple et
pertinents
pour aller faire du business à
l'international de passer par un hub
international qui n'existera jamais en
bourgogne franche comté faut être lucide
bref
mais au delà de ça c'est se dire
travaillons ensemble beaucoup plus que
ce que nous faisons
essayons de mettre des entreprises et
des entrepreneurs dans toutes les
organisations qui peuvent exister pour
des décisions globales
on peut participer à ça et au contraire
et on est prêt à le faire et puis il y
eut une notion d'employabilité il ya
beaucoup de pertes d'emplois on en a
parlé sur certaines régions alors qu'il
y à l inverse énormément de chefs
d'entreprises qui ne trouvent pas de
cela le fait qu'elle peut faire la
région pour ça le premier problème
effectivement pour le développement des
entreprises chez nous mais comme dans
toutes les autres régions
c'est la question de l'accès aux
compétences c'est la question des
recrutements
aujourd'hui les entreprises ont des
carnets de commandes que des fois elles
sont obligées de refuser parce qu'elles
ne trouvent pas les personnes dont elles
ont besoin
donc nous avons un plan massif de
formation grâce à l'état on peut
critiquer l'état sur certaines choses
mais d'autres reconnaître
l'état fait un effort sans précédent qui
n'a jamais été fait depuis 40 ou 50 ans
sur les questions de formation et donc
nous sur mute 200 millions aujourd'hui
nous avons 200 millions plus de 200
millions d'euros dans les quatre ans qui
viennent pour des programmes massifs de
formation pour aller chercher des jeunes
des moins jeunes qui n'ont jamais eu
accès à la formation et pour opérer ce
lien avec les besoins des entreprises
les besoins traditionnels parce que
c'est pas que le numérique qui a besoin
de nouvelles compétences et besoins
traditionnels de soudeur de fraser de
chaudronnier et là on touche après un
problème culturel qui est le déficit de
notre population par rapport aux métiers
de l'industrie
on a mal à notre industrie et moi ça me
fait très mal dans une industrie dans
une région aussi puissante que la nôtre
au niveau industriel
on ne croit plus à notre industrie alors
qu'on peut y faire carrière
alors qu'on peut y être heureux et là
c'est vraiment un problème culturel
qu'on travaille avec tout le milieu
patronal avec le rectorat pour faire
prendre conscience qu'il y a vraiment un
avenir dans notre industrie
vous allez passer le micro si ça vous
dérange pas à philippe pillot donc qui
est syndicaliste force ouvrière qui
travaille chez alstom alstom à trois
sites en bourgogne franche comté belfort
ornans et le creusot si je ne m'abuse
et vous aviez justement une question à
poser par rapport à la politique
ferroviaire et les entreprises oui alors
ect ect alstom parce que j'ai fini ma
carrière mais je continue à travailler
dans la filière ferroviaire ou pour la
fédération fo et donc le contrat de
filière va être signée à la fin du mois
à lille et vous avez vécu toutes les
difficultés d'alstom et différentes
péripéties
je crois que on aurait besoin quand même
et je constate aussi que l'industrie a
des difficultés qu'on travaillait
ensemble mais également les
organisations syndicales dès qu'on est
souvent oubliée on a eu du mal à vous
rencontrer sur ce dossier vous avez d
alstom ont passé des commandes et c'est
très bien vous aider alstom dans la
recherche et le développement et c'est
très bien on a un problème de formation
c'est clair on a eu 1
une étude faite par lui et même et on
sait que le ferroviaire à un avenir
parce que au niveau environnemental
on aura créé des emplois et derrière on
a quand même des difficultés à recruter
là je vous rejoins tous autour de la
table
comment fait-on pour être acteur et pas
spectateur et c'est j'aimerais savoir ce
que vous souhaitez mettre en place pour
justement nous aider à recruter et à
faire vis de nos entreprises et créer
des emplois mais pour le recrutement
c'est clair on a des appels à projets
toutes les semaines pour monter des
formations qui correspondent aux besoins
que les entreprises nous ont fait
remonter
est ce qu'on faisait depuis trois ans ou
quatre ans est multiplié par trois ou
quatre actuellement
donc là on met le paquet le plus
possible pour alstom je voudrais dire
que la région la contribution de la
région au delà des 400 millions d'euros
d'investissement qu'elle nous avons
procédé depuis une dizaine d'année 1
pour la le renouvellement du matériel
nous sommes engagés dans le train
hydrogène et là nous avons poussé les
feux avec alstom pour que probablement
une des premières lignes qui accueillera
un train hydrogène en 2022 je crois un
ca soit chez nous ça sera sur la liste
ce sera en bourgogne 1 sur auxerre la
roche donc on pousse les feux de la
recherche on pousse les commandes
et puis pour la formation eh bien on
travaille régulièrement pour avec les
chefs d'entreprises pour savoir quels
sont leurs besoins et mettre en face
effectivement les informations
nécessaires et ça on le multiplie un
donc cesser le sujet presque numéro un
c'est vraiment la responsabilité
première de la région
j'ai aimé comment dire réconcilier les
parents les jeunes les professeurs aussi
avec le monde de l'industrie
ça ne se fait pas en quelques mois ni
même en quelques années c'est vraiment
un processus de 10 ans mais moi je vois
avec le recul par rapport à il ya cinq
ans ben des sections d'apprentissage qui
formait
qui forment à l'industrie et qui ne
trouvait pas preneur recommence à
trouver preneur donc ça veut dire qu'il
ya une petite bascule qui commence à se
faire mais là c'est vraiment un gros
gros travail culturel vous avez parlé de
filières agricoles aussi les filières
industrielles à banneux absolument de
franche comté bourgogne franche comté
quand même la deuxième région au niveau
ferroviaire des entreprises après les
hôtes france eux ils ont un comité
régional de filière ferroviaire et je
pense que là aussi il faut qu'on
travaille par filière
alors sur la filière sur la filière
ferroviaire je voudrais quand même dire
qu'on a mis en place un pôle de un pôle
industriel au creusot pour la
maintenance du ferroviaire avec le mée
captyn clusters ou la grâce à
l'investissement de la région
on est en train de développer des
emplois pour la maintenance ferroviaire
dans toute la france et c'est unique en
france le nez katyn kloster donc il nous
faut sur l'économie être à la fois sur
l'industrie sur l'industrie lourde sur
l'industrie automobile sur l'industrie
ferroviaire nous faut être aussi près de
toutes les start up qui se développe
dans le domaine du numérique parce que
l'avenir il est quand même beaucoup là
et on a des pépites extraordinaire en
bourgogne comme en france comptait 1
vous avez entendu parler ces jours ci du
lancement de la carte du diabète
c'est une start-up bourguignonne qui est
derrière nous avons à besançon covalia
on fit là il a fait beaucoup de startups
qui développe des produits qui sont des
produits de demain
et quand on va à l'extérieur dans les
grandes conventions d'affaires puisqu'on
pousse beaucoup on aide beaucoup les les
startups à se faire connaître à
l'extérieur mais on se rend compte que
la délégation bourgogne franche comté
elle n'a pas à rougir elle est toujours
très très conséquente le vivier des
start-up largement issu de l'indus delà
de l'université d'ahlia reste deux
minutes et j'avais fait miroiter à
sandrine décembre que je la lui redonner
la parole sur le numérique mais elle
voit bien mon regard que je vais pas lui
redonner juste un tout petit peu parce
qu'on a deux minutes de la fin
d'émission un tout petit peu une
question politique
marie-guite dufay quand même sens nous
voilà si on se base sur les premiers
sondages des européennes est ce qu'on
peut pas se poser la question
vous allez dire c'est un peu brutal de
la représentativité de votre majorité
on sait aujourd'hui que le ps pèse un
peu plus de
5 % dans les sondages et l'air est à 13%
pas beaucoup plus haut voilà est-ce que
ça vous pose question ça d'être élu à la
tête d'une majorité qui aujourd'hui
représente plus vraiment paysage
politique du pays
il ya la transition numérique et la
transition écologique il ya aussi les
transitions politiques
ça c'est clair que la famille à laquelle
j'appartiens elle est en pleine
transition en pleine évolution
mais vous savez nous avons un plan de
mandat c'est notre ciment nous nous
sommes fixés des enjeux au niveau
économique au niveau écologique au
niveau aussi de la fraternité faire de
cette région une région fraternelle par
la culture par le sport eh bien nous
nous y tenons
et cela nous permet de se dépasser de
dépasser cette question on n'est pas sûr
au sein de la conduite de l'action
régionale sur des enjeux politiques
parce que sur sur le développement local
et développement régional n'est pas ça
qui prime ce ne sont pas ces enjeux
politiques maintenant mais vous aviez
appelé à voter manuel macron quand même
il ya deux ans oui c'est vrai mais ça ne
change rien à la conduite des affaires
régionales et le 26 mai pour les
élections européennes vous allez voter
ps ou d'abord je ne sais pas je ne va
pas vous dire maintenant pour qui je
vais voter parce que on est quand même
dans une dans un brouillard très très
complet la famille à laquelle
j'appartiens n'a pas encore de liste n'a
pas commencé sa campagne
moi je souhaiterais pouvoir donner ma
voix au pse parti socialiste fin au
groupe du parti socialiste
ça va être votre conclusion d'un guide
terminé sujet n'est pas épuisé bien sûr
nous arrivons à la fin de ce numéro
exceptionnel de dimanche en politique
merci à vous tous et outre d'être venu
contribuer à ce débat
merci mon mari qui du fait de nous avoir
accueillis ici et merci à vous de nous
suivre nombreux tous les dimanches et
restez avec nous pour la partie
nationale 2
dimanche en politique bon dimanche or
voient parfois au revoir et merci